okay another intersection
another death another shrine the same
city
dante writes shooting by police during
the trial
seeking justice for george floyd has
stirred up
anger trauma they bring a lot of
hate to this world
and it has nothing to do with you or you
but it's just that
do we stand up without
hurting you or you twenty-year-old dante
wright was shot
during a routine traffic stop on sunday
the police were quick to release body
cam footage
showing the moment they claimed the
officer shot him by accident
and three days later officer kim potter
has been charged
with second-degree manslaughter a much
faster response than after the death
of george floyd but many here feel
nothing's changed
there's no way you can mistake a taser
for a gun not if you've been on the
field for 26 years
i can't see that especially if you're a
veteran police yeah it's not okay
the decision to charge officer kim
potter so quickly
is undoubtedly a bid to try and calm
this community
but many here are still unhappy that she
resigned instead of being fired
and many simply don't buy the police
explanation
she fired her handgun instead of her
taser by accident
it's added to tension here amid the
trial of former officer derek chauvin
for the death of george floyd
the defense continues to present its
case
arguing his restraint of mr floyd was an
appropriate use of force
with a former medical examiner
testifying exhaust fumes
drugs and a heart condition caused his
death
mr floyd had a sudden cardiac arrhythmia
or cardiac arrhythmia
due to his atherosclerotic and
hypertensive
heart disease he would have the
toxicology the fentanyl
and methamphetamine
there is exposure to a vehicle exhaust
all of those combined to
cause mr floyd's death
the city had been braced for protests
during the trial
dante wright's death has now sparked
nightly unrest
his shooting would have caused outrage
regardless
but there's a sense it couldn't have
come at a worse time for this community
sally lock with sky news minneapolis